[Applaus]
[Musik]
die ukraine ist so ein weiterer paris
hilton über den staaten jedes mal wenn
über sie in den nachrichten rede ist
kann man getrost davon ausgehen dass das
wohl nichts das ist in den letzten
jahrzehnten war die um keine nicht nur
schauplatz des bisher schlimmsten
atomunfalls oder eines krieges mit
russland sondern auch der schlimmsten
korruptionsskandale die ihr euch
vorstellen
ukrainische politiker und parasiten
haben aber noch eine weitere
gemeinsamkeit ziemlich die kohle und in
beiden fällen meinen wir damit geld nach
dem fall der sowjetunion wurde die
wirtschaft der ukraine nicht mehr staat
und dessen politikern verwaltet sondern
stattdessen von den politikern äusserst
nahe stehenden freundin des staates es
handelt sich hierbei um die sogenannten
oligarchen und man findet sie in allen
politischen parteien sowohl dem
pro-russischen als auch denen die über
russland kritisch eingestellten
so ist beispielsweise der ehemalige
präsident petro poroschenko auch als
schokoladen könig bekannt weil in der
größten süßwarenhersteller des landes
gehört die ehemalige ministerpräsidentin
julia timoschenko hat den namen
gasprinzessin da sie in der gasindustrie
stinkreich geworden ist der aktuelle
präsident zielinski ist zwar noch nicht
mehr der sondern von hause aus
eigentlich schauspieler
[Musik]
vor seiner kandidatur für das
präsidentenamt spielte er in einer
comedyserie einen präsidenten und das
wohl so überzeugen dass in das volk
anschließend zur realen präsidenten des
landes wählte die frage ist allerdings
ob der comedian auch so bekannt und
beliebt geworden wäre wenn ihnen der
medienmagnat und milliardär igor
kolanoski nicht tatkräftig gefördert
hätte miller wäre und oligarchen wohin
man schaut das ist alltag in der
ukrainischen politik und zum leidwesen
meiner mission nicht nur ukrainische
oligarchen mit sondern auch ausländische
trotz verbündete drängen auf
führungswechsel bei naftogas in der
ukraine anscheinend ging es darum
günstige bedingungen für den verkauf von
verflüssigtem us erdgas an die ukraine
zu erhalten
wie sich ein ukrainisches gasunternehmen
mitten in trans amtsenthebung drama
wiederfand trank und seine verbündeten
haben ukrainische beamte dazu gedrängt
gegen den ehemaligen vizepräsidenten joe
biden zu ermitteln einen von jobs
wahrscheinlich einen trend bei den
kommenden präsidentschaftswahlen
dadurch wurde das komplizierte anhebung
verfahren gegen trump ausgelöst wow was
für ein drama welchen grund hatte
ausgerechnet donald trump sich derart
tief in die ukrainische belange
einzumischen dass er seinen gegnern
damit munition für ein
amtsenthebungsverfahren lieferte was ist
gerade an der ukraine so wichtig dass
sie ihn so viel ärger wert sein könnte
aber moment mal kommt ist nicht der
einzige der sich im ukrainischen sumpf
verstrickt hat denn auch sein
hauptkonkurrent der demokratische
präsidentschaftskandidatur beiden steckt
über beide ohren drin
[Applaus]
[Musik]
ukraine untersucht gelegte
aufzeichnungen der gespräche zwischen
beiden und poroschenko biden versprach
angeblich die ukraine würde als
gegenleistung für die entlastung des
generalstaatsanwalts sektor schock in
eine kreditgarantie in höhe von einer
milliarde dollar erhalten
shocking leitete damals die ermittlungen
gegen die gasfirma boris für die hand
der beiden gearbeitet hatte der sohn des
damaligen vizepräsidenten und jetzigen
demokratischen us
präsidentschaftskandidaten poroschenko
bekräftigte dass die bänder eine
fälschung sein und bezeichnete ihre
veröffentlichung als eine finte des
kreml
soso trump beiden putin sie alle wollen
am ganz großen rad drehen problem achse
dieses rats ist ausgerechnet die ukraine
es sieht tatsächlich danach aus als
würde ein großer teil des diesjährigen
us präsidentschaftswahlkampfs auf
ukrainischem boden ausgetragen werden
wie aber konnte es überhaupt so weit
kommen was ist sowieso dass an der
ukraine bei einem eigentlich verarmten
land das den meisten nicht gerade als
internationales machtzentrum bekannt ist
in denen das schicksal der weltpolitik
entschieden wird wieso ist die ukraine
aber trotzdem für das weltgeschehen so
bedeutend
schaut mal in einem früheren video haben
wir euch erzählt dass russland der
wichtigste gasversorgung europas ist so
bezieht deutschland 60 prozent seines
erdgases von russischen unternehmen wie
gazprom oder auslöst und wie kommt
dieses gas bei uns an
das meiste davon kommt aus gasleitungen
die über ukrainisches gebiet führen was
bedeutet das alles bedeutet dass die
ukraine immer noch einen hot dogs im
gasgeschäft darstellt und hier kommt
wladimir putin ins spiel
auch heute noch ist putin auf die
ukraine angewiesen europa mit gas zu
versorgen aber wie ihr wisst befinden
sich die beziehungen zwischen putin und
kiew in einem um es mal so auszudrücken
es ist kompliziert status manche leute
sagen ewige liebe halte bis 110 jahre
nach jahrzehnten der gegenseitigen liebe
oder slawischen brüderlichkeit will die
regierung von putins russland nichts
mehr wissen wie ihr euch vorstellen
könnt macht russland diese politische
scheidung nicht gerade glücklich jedes
mal beim russlands gas durch das
ukrainische territorium fließt muss ist
eine ex uns sondern an transitgebühren
zahlen aber das ist noch nicht alles
solange russland von der ukraine
abhängig ist und sein gas nach europa zu
exportieren hat kiew eine bessere
verhandlungsposition und das gilt sowohl
für verhandlungen mit moskau als auch
mit brüssel
mit anderen worten der ukraine ist uns
wichtig so lange wir sie für unser gas
brauchen
was ist also prozessstrategie seht euch
mal folgendes
[Musik]
russland besteht auf neue pipeline zur
umgehung der ukraine und die europäer
sind damit einverstanden
ja liebe zuschauer russland will die
ukraine von ihren gasleitung abschneiden
dadurch würde die ukraine ihren gesamten
strategischen vorteil verlieren
es würde bedeuten dass
höchstwahrscheinlich im falle einer
erneuten russischen invasion weder die
usa noch die europäische union der
ukraine helfen würden die frage lautet
also kann diese strategie funktionieren
soll die europäische union zu lassen was
russland die ukraine um geht heute
werden wir all diese fragen beantworten
aber bevor wir das tun lasst uns einen
blick in die geschichte werfen wenn du
nicht mir gehören kannst du wirst du
auch keinem anderen gehören im jahr 2000
kam 70 prozent des nach europa
importierten russischen gases über die
ukraine genauer gesagt kann ist aus dem
sogenannten bruderschafts gas film diese
kathrein wurde in der zeit der
sowjetunion gebaut und gewann mit der
steigenden nachfrage nach russischem gas
immer mehr an bedeutung die anderen 30
prozent kamen aus den ja mal rohr in
weißrussland aber was ein anderer
geschichte als die sowjetunion
zusammenbrach wurde dem kreis zu einer
unabhängigen nation in diesem moment mit
der die politiker in kiew ein mögliches
geschäft russland hat zwar die
gasvorkommen aber sie brauchen uns um
diese an die deutschen zu verkaufen also
sollten sie auch es darf dich transit
gebühren zahlen
dank der sogenannten transitrechte wurde
die ukrainische gesellschaft naftogaz zu
einem giganten
und das obwohl die ukraine kaum über
eigene gasvorkommen ihr euch vorstellen
könnt geht es hier um mehr als nur um
wirtschaft sowohl in russland als auch
in der ukraine hat alles auch eine
politische bedeutung
jedes mal wenn in kiew eine pro
russische regierung an der macht ist
verkaufte das prompt den ukrainer stars
äußerst ist hatten in der ukraine jedoch
russland find ich hier politiker das
sagen wurden die preise plötzlich stark
erhöht um den ukrainern das leben so
schwer wie möglich sind also eine
klassische zuckerbrot und peitsche hatte
wir haben euch das bereits in einem
anderen video erklärt den ersten aus der
reihe über das russische gas handel
zwischen russland und der ukraine
führten in den jahren 2006 und 2009 zu
einer liefer kürze
während der letzten kürzung der von 2009
wurde auch im rest der europäer das gas
abgedreht und genau in diesem moment
verlegte sich russland auf eine neue
strategie putin rief seine freunde den
ehemaligen deutschen kanzler und
derzeitigen rosneft präsidenten gerd
schröder und ich will da wiederum rief
die derzeitige bundeskanzlerin angela
merkel an
und so wurde das erste projekt zur
umgehung der ukraine verabschiedet die
nord-stream-pipeline diese pipeline
führt durch die ostsee also von
russlands direkt nach deutschland
ein jahr später im jahr 2010 wir waren
der pro-russische viktor janukowitsch
die ukrainischen präsidentschaftswahlen
für die ukraine kehrten damit friedliche
zeiten und günstige gaspreise zurück
2014 jedoch ereignete sich der euro
weiter
erinnert ihr euch noch an diese proteste
in kiew janukowitsch wurde zu fall
gebracht und eine brandneue
eu-freundliche russland jedoch sehr
kritisch gegenüberstehende regierung
entstand in der ukraine und in diesem
moment sagte putin wenn du nicht mehr
gehören kannst desto auch keine andere
gehören 2015 hat das frauen das größte
russischen gasunternehmen den
ultimativen plan gestartet die ukraine
zu umgehen
[Musik]
zum einen wurde das nord stream zwei
projekt das durch die ostsee für den
angriff genommen zum anderen baut
gazprom auf der südseite den texten der
gas durch das schwarze meer bis in die
türkei transportiert
laut den gastraum präsidenten wird die
gute alte bruderschafts pipeline bis zum
jahr 2020 weniger als zehn prozent von
den transportieren sich früher
weitergeleitet hat aber einen moment
denn bisher scheint es so als ob
russland hier der bösewicht ist uns die
ukraine nur ein armes opfer oder in
wirklichkeit ist dies jedoch noch viel
komplizierter
lasst uns mal noch ein bisschen tiefer
in die sache ein stein der ukraine schön
bohrloch
naftogaz ist weit mehr als nur ein gas
unternehmen tatsächlich handelt es sich
um eine gigantische
arbeitsbeschaffungsmaßnahmen mehr als
75.000 menschen sind sie angestellt ja
ihr habt richtig gehört nur eines
deutlich zu machen das äquivalent zum
naftogaz in polen bmw das sich ebenfalls
im staatsbesitz befindet beschäftigt nur
25.000 mitarbeiter mit anderen worten in
der ukraine ist man ein niemand wenn man
keinen verwandten hat herr nach dem glas
arbeitet ihr euch vorstellen könnt ist
naftogaz ein schwarzes loch im
ukrainischen haushalt bei dem es so
aussieht als würde sich paris hilton
persönlich um die buchhaltung sondern
müsst ihr bei einem staatlichen
unternehmen das so viele angestellte
beschäftigt verschwindet das geld
einfach und niemand weiß warum laut dem
institut für wirtschaftsforschung und
politikberatung einem ukrainischen think
tank verliert naftogas jährlich mehr als
drei milliarden dollar durch korruption
dieses unternehmen verbucht dauerhafte
finanzielle verluste und wir sprechen
hier nicht von peanuts erst im jahr 2014
machte der verlust der naftogaz sechs
prozent des gesamten ukrainischen das
produkt aus aber genau in jenem jahr
2014 kann der euro weiter an statt und
das veränderte alles und zwar sehr
schnell zum beispiel hier
ukrainische polizei verhaftet nach dass
vorstandspositionen bakulin soweit sieht
es ganz gut aus sowohl die europäische
union als auch der iwf haben keinen dazu
gedrängt ihre hausaufgaben zu machen und
es scheint als würde sie es zumindest
versuchen andere kowalew wurde als neuer
geschäftsführer eingesetzt und er begann
damit die korruption und die
abhängigkeit von russland einzudämmen
und erst werdet euch vielleicht fragen
hat das geklappt
gsd königs verbesserungen in der
initiative zur transparenz der
speicherung an der ukrainische
gaskonzern naftogaz tritt den
gasspeicher inventar ag easy plus bei
und plötzlich hast du ja fast gewinnen
nach jahrzehnten finanzieller verluste
machen sie heute und 13 prozent
der ukrainische staatseinnahmen aus und
ihr werdet ihr euch vielleicht fragen
wie hat komponiert das alles hinbekommen
wie lautet die zauberformel nun auf der
einen seite wurde die regulierung des
gaspreises durch die regierung die sie
beim staatlichen monopol nun mal üblich
ist aufgehoben
das bedeutete für die verbraucher mit
den super billigem gas welches die
keiner die ganzen jahre über gewohnt
waren war essen aus 100 nach dem gast
die preise auf ein niveau angehoben das
dem anderer europäischer länder entsteht
auf der anderen seite hat coppola putin
mit die sagen wir mal quer denken
überrascht das brom wollte die gaspreise
für die ukraine erhöhen aber nicht für
den rest der europäischen länder
was hat den kahlen also getan anstatt
mit moskau zu streiten begann team keine
gas von anderen europäischen ländern wie
der slowakei zu kaufen aber manchmal
gibt es in der slowakei überhaupt
gasvorkommen natürlich nicht noch mal
aus die verträge mit gazprom besagen
dass russland die kontrolle über das gas
verliert sobald dieses ihrem land sind
das bedeutet dass der käufer mit dem gas
machen kann was er will
das russische gas wird also durch die
bürgerschaft pipeline in die slowakei
transportiert und dann über diese
leitung wieder zurück in die ukraine
geführt
somit kauft die slowakei gas von
russland dem keine wiederum das gleiche
gas von der slowakei an dieses manövers
hatte naftogas seine importkosten um ein
viertel gesenkt aber das ist erst der
anfang
naftogaz steigert den reingewinn 2009 10
um das fünfeinhalb fache und zahlt 48,2
milliarden ukrainische redner an
dividend enough to gas ukraine group
erwirtschaftete im jahr 2009 10 einen
nettogewinn von 63,3 milliarden
ukrainische griwna dieser wurde auftrag
einer zahlung von 2,9 milliarden us
dollar durch die russische gazprom
erzielt diese zahlung hatte das
schiedsgericht der stockholmer
handelskammer im rahmen der festsetzung
des gas transit preises festgelegt doch
leider meine lieben diese politik
zuschauer spielte sich auch dieser sieg
gegenüber russland nicht ohne einen
korruptionsskandal eben
selbstbedienungsladen naftogas selbst
[Musik]
anti korruptions büro gewährte naftogas
angestellt zugang zu nehmen muss über
sechsstellige boni die untersuchung
ergab dass das schiedsgericht der
handelskammer in stockholm im februar
2018 den forderungen von naftogaz
trachte eintreibung von transit schulden
der russischen gazprom in höhe von
insgesamt 4,6 7 milliarden us-dollar
nachgab
im april des selben jahres gewährte der
aufsichtsrat von naftogaz dem vorstand
und einigen anderen mitarbeitern boni in
höhe von einem prozent der arbitrage
summe also insgesamt 43,6 millionen
dollar
es wird darauf hingewiesen dass zum
zeitpunkt der entscheidung noch keine
gelder auf dem konto von naftogaz
eingetroffen waren
bei der untersuchung wurde festgestellt
dass die vertretung der interessen von
naftogaz in stockholm hier überhaupt
nicht von naftogaz mitarbeitern sondern
von einer anwaltskanzlei wahrgenommen
wurde
tja meine lieben zuschauer von visual
politik der korruptions berg bei
naftogaz ist ebenso gewaltig das ist
unglaublich lange dauern wird ihn
vollends abzutragen wenn sich die
ukraine nämlich vollständig an die
europäischen normen anpassen wollen
würde möchte sie ihren gasmarkt
liberalisiert nach das wäre dann kein
monopolist mehr und der konzern müsste
in mehrere kleine unternehmen aufgeteilt
werden als unternehmen würde sich dann
auf die gasproduktion konzentrieren ein
anderes auf die steuerung des verbrauchs
und so weiter und wie ihr euch
vorstellen könnt tauchen hier bereits
die ersten probleme auf
eu und ukraine im tauziehen um die
aufteilung von naftogas wahrscheinlich
könnt ihr es euch bereits denken so sehr
sich kumuliert auch anstrengend das
ungesehene reinigen es haben einfach
bereits zu viele organischen zu lange
ihre spieße nannte das unternehmen und
zwar im besitz des staates sein aber das
bedeutet noch lange nicht ist keine
millionärs gehälter und
bestechungsgelder in enormer höhe nach
außen fließen und es ist sehr schwer das
von einem tag auf den anderen zu
unterbinden und liebe zum chanson
selbstverständlich hat russland für
diesen fall eine perfekt definierte
agenda
und wir sind andere
[Musik]
wirtschaft versus geopolitik deutschland
hat es durchgesetzt
die pipeline nord stream 2 wird gebaut
sowohl brüssel also auch washington sind
dagegen
tatsächlich war donald trump der größte
kritiker er sagte so etwas wie selbst
paris hilton würde einen besseren job
als deutschland in bezug auf eine gute
energie politik machen und jetzt fragt
ihr euch vielleicht wie ist es möglich
dass sich angela merkel von wladimir
putin hat verführen lassen
ja es ist allen klar dass der ehemalige
deutsche kanzler gerhard schröder putins
man in europa ist aber da steckt noch
mehr dahinter
grundsätzlich steckt deutschland in
einem großen dilemma große teile seiner
schlüsselindustrien bank deren
deutschland eine gewaltige
wirtschaftsmacht ist sind extrem glas
ohne gas geht in der deutschen
wirtschaft nichts mehr und die sicherer
und billiger die gasversorgung desto
besser und nord stream 2 stellt die
beste option für die deutsche wirtschaft
da sich von möglichen gas kriegen
zwischen der ukraine und russland
unabhängig zu machen
[Musik]
und noch 10 2 stellt die beste option
für die deutsche wirtschaft da sich
gegen mögliche risiken eines gaskriegs
zwischen der ukraine und russland
abzusichern das problem jedoch ist diese
pipeline erhöht deutschlands
abhängigkeit von russland nur noch
weiter in der zwischenzeit kommt putin
vor glück kann nicht mehr aus dem jubeln
er kann die ukraine umgehen und
gleichzeitig auch noch ihre wirtschaft
zerstören
in diesem zusammenhang sind die
absichten russlands offensichtlicher als
die deiner ex wenn sie nur mal einen
kaffee trinken gehen möchte wollte ein
beispiel
werft einen blick auf diese karte das
ist das schwarze meer und dieses kleine
meer im norden das ist das offene diese
beide meere durch die straße von kertsch
miteinander reden in die ukraine hat
zwei wichtige häfen ins spiel
was hat russland angeboten sie haben
eine brücke direkt über die strasse von
ter stegen in der brücke die es den
meisten schiffen und möglich macht das
social mehr zu erreichen oder zu
verlassen es wagt euch vielleicht warum
liegt deutschland in vielen anderen
kleinen geht es um eifersucht wohl kaum
die sache ist die je schlechter die
russisch freundliche ukraine stricken
und abschneidet desto besser stehen eben
die chancen für die hübschen kandidaten
bei den wachen
[Musik]
zwar ist heute nach dem schokoladen
könig der übrigens ironischerweise
diabetes hat eine antirussische comedian
präsident aber putin denkt langfristig
hofft darauf dass die ukraine eines
tages das lachen endgültig vergeht dass
sie ihre träume von einem leben nach
westlichem vorbild endgültig begraben
und dann die harte hand des kremls auch
die ukraine regiert in der zwischenzeit
lautet die frage für euch was würdet ihr
tun wenn ihr die entscheidung für
deutschland vernichtet würdet ihr das
billige russische gas nehmen und damit
die ukraine im stich lassen oder würdet
ihr die wettbewerbsfähigkeit eures
landes zugunsten von politischen
interessen opfern bitte hinterlasst eure
antworten im kommentarbereich unten wenn
euch dieses video gefallen hat gibt uns
einen daumen hoch und immer sehen wir
uns das nächste
[Musik]